وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قال انه لا
توجد مؤشرات على ان الاجسام الطائره التي
تم اسقاطها في الاجواء الامريكيه مرتبطه
ببرنامج التجسس للصين
في كلمه له ان التقييم الحالي لاجهزه
الاستخبارات الامريكيه يشير الى ترجيح
فرضيه ارتباط هذه الاجسام الطائره بشركات
خاصه او بمؤسسات بحثيه لا علاقه لها
بالحكومه
اصدرت امرا باسقاط الاجسام الثلاثه بسبب
مخاطرها على الحركه الجويه وكذلك مخاطر
التجسسها على المنشات الحساسه تصرفنا
بدافع من الحذر يسعى الجيشين الامريكي
والكندي الى انتشال حطام هذه الاجسام حتى
نتمكن من معرفه المزيد عنها لا نعرف بعد
طبيعه الاجسام بالضبط لكن لا شيء في الوقت
الحالي يوحي بانها مرتبطه ببرنامج التجسس
الصيني او لدوله اخرى التقييم الحالي
للاجهزه الاستخباراتيه يشير الى ان هذه
الاجسام هي على الارجح مناطيض مرتبطه
بشركات خاصه او مؤسسات ترفيهيه او بحثيه
للدراسه الطقس او غيره